so
to those watching at home are members of
the public i do apologize we've had some
technical issues and we do have to go
back to
our item four declarations of interest
so i know i have councillor dharam
i'm afraid we have to go back to item
four declarations oh in that case
chairman i have a non-continuing
interest that's a member of essex county
council who have secretary consultees in
respect of highways flooding and other
matters thank you and councillor fleming
thank you chair a non-pecunery as a
member of essex county council who are
statutory consultees thank you thank you
i don't see any others so we'll go on to
item five which is our first planning
application
um the land
to the rear of hillbarn retro lane
wasn't wood and mortimer
do you have
public speakers on that um
that that'll be to follow the
presentation so when you're ready please
thank you chair
so plan and permission is sought for the
conversion of an existing equestrian
storage barn to form offices and
associated development
here we have the location plan you can
see the site is accessed
from rectory road
and it's to the rear of the dwelling
here
we have the existing site plan which
shows the existing barn the existing
outbuilding in the corner
and the level of hard standing currently
on the site
and then we have the block plan
as you can see the level of built form
on the site will not be altered
and the car parking area is proposed to
be finished in grass creek
that's to the front of the building here
we've got the existing elevations
and the proposed elevations which shows
the changes to the fenestration scheme
the existing floor plan
and the proposed floor plan
and then we've got the existing
outbuilding on the left hand side and
the proposed alterations are shown on
the right hand side
and then we've got photographs of the
site
and photographs of the access track and
some more of the site
the proposed development is a
resubmission of a previously refused
scheme the additional information which
demonstrates a justifiable and
functional need for the
sorry for the proposed development is
considered to offset the harm
arising from the urbanization of the
site as the level of alterations are not
considered to go beyond what's necessary
for the site to function as an office
unit
and the min and there's minimal visual
impact to the wider area
the proposal would provide an employment
generating use
and could potentially support an
existing and established business
the proposal would provide support to
the rural economy in accordance with
criterion e of policy s8
there's sufficient space on the site to
provide parking provision
and the proposals not considered
to result in adverse impact on the
neighbouring occupiers therefore the
application is recommended for approval
thank you chair
thank you
so our first public speaker is mr steven
goff who is an objector you'd like to
come forward please sir pick any chair
on the outer ring
make yourself comfortable please do use
the microphone and you will have two
minutes from when you start to speak and
i do time that very exactly so
you start when you're ready and we'll
start the time thank you
good evening members my name is stephen
goff and together with my family we live
at hill place one of the adjoining
properties to the application site
we've previously registered our strong
objections to this application as we
simply do not accept that any benefits
which may accrue to this proposal will
outweigh the harm which this development
will cause
however in view of the officer's
recommendation if members are minded to
approve the application tonight there
are a number of matters which we have
concerns about which would be very
obliged if you would consider during
your deliberations
in terms of drainage we're extremely
worried about drainage the applicant
declares in the application forms that
connection will be made to
to the public file sewer there is no
there is no public sewer in wood and
mortimer as the applicant will knows
and the we would respectfully request
that no decision is made until this
matter is is resolved
conditions on lighting should be
strengthened um we would require if
possible a condition that would require
dis details of all lighting including
hours of operation
and make it clear that no external
lighting would be permissible on the
access driveway
advertisements there's nothing in the
office's recommendation that would
prevent advertisements or signage on the
site and this could have considerable
impact where it to be uncontrolled
so we would respectfully request a
condition to be added to prevent any
advertisement including any
advertisement otherwise permitted
under the town of country planning
control of advertisement regulations
and finally chairman condition five this
is an extremely important condition as
it limits the use of this building to
any office use within classy small g
little one
and for no other purpose
we would respectfully request that in
addition to the no other purpose the
wording is added including any other
purpose ancillary to the use as an
office
and perhaps you might seek confirmation
from your officers that this condition
would prevent any future use for
residential purposes under the new class
m a the part three of the permitted
development order
thank you very much
i will be referring to the officers for
answers to that but in the meantime i
think we'll have our other public
speaker
who is mr matthew wood the agent
same rules please mr wood just make
yourself comfortable please use the
microphone
you have two minutes precisely from when
you start to speak
good evening to members as you will
recall this planning application is a
resubmission of a similar proposal
refused by members in january 2021
so since this refusal the applicant has
positively and proactively engaged with
officers for pre-application discussions
in order to address the outstanding
issues relating to demonstrating a
justifiable and functional need for the
proposals
and the impact of such development on
its countryside location
as a result this application
resubmission to demonstrate a
justifiable and functional need for such
small-scale development as
comprehensively set out by officers
within their committee report
accordingly in line with local and
national planning policy the principle
of this development is acceptable
in terms of the scheme detail this has
been revised in line with officer
pre-app
feedback with officers now concluding
that such alterations
will not go beyond what is necessary for
the building to function as an office
with any visual impact the proposal
would have on the wider area being
clearly outweighed by the economic and
employment
benefits
given the nature and intensity of the
proposed office use it is not considered
that such a change of use would
adversely impact upon such interests as
again confirmed by officers
in addition there is extensive the
vegetation screening to the south
obscuring the barn
from wider views with a two meter high
close boarded fence and trees doing the
same to the west the applicant also
notes the supporting comments
from mr marshall to the north
notwithstanding this the applicant is
agreeable to adding additional screening
as may be appropriate
the proposals also continue to be fully
acceptable in highway terms with the
highway authority again raising no
objection to this planning application
in conclusion these proposals represent
a sustainable and policy compliant form
of redevelopment as confirmed by the
positive officer the recommendation
therefore the members are urged to
support this recommendation and grant
detailed planning permission accordingly
thank you very much for your time
um
okay members before i
open your discussion i was just going to
ask mr johnson for any views he has at
this stage on the requests made about
the um conditions
and please use your microphone because
of the streaming thank you
we've got lighting restriction abuse the
drainage issue and advertising that's
not necessarily in the right order but
yes um
the the matter of drainage um has been
conditioned
uh within the within the application
um
let me just go to the details of it
um
sorry to spare me a second
now they're the um
the
the
the gentleman who spoke in objection to
the scheme
said that there's no
drainage within the area obviously
that's not something we're aware of
but for
before the development can commence
the details of drainage would need to be
approved
so no development can take place
until those matters have been satisfied
so that answers that question yes that
one thank you i know we can restrict
lighting we can certainly ask for any
lighting proposals to be submitted in
writing
well that's right and there is there is
a condition relating to that at
thank you you might like to think about
um restriction abuse and the advertising
in the meantime i'm going to open these
things up
yeah there are holes but yes in addition
to that molding is i don't you know
malden has an area of special control
for advertisements which cover which go
even beyond just what is you know you
can erect under deemed uh consent
so there are those con controls in in
place i mean the one thing i would just
mention the um that the gentleman did
mention about
um lighting condition extending to you
know the lighting within the building
itself
um
if if i recall that the the lighting
controls wouldn't normally go to that
extent but the hours of operation of the
business has been conditioned
uh up to six six six o'clock
thank you i've got three hands out and
remembers i'm just gonna ask to go to
you for you know discussion and any
questions you have and i'm hoping out of
that will come
a proposal um counselor charles i
suppose in fact
first i think would you like you called
it in would you like to go first or
later
okay if i'm here but i'd just like to
pick up on a few points i mean first of
all
clearly i think we can see that the
employment case seems to be uh quite
well made compared to the previous
application
so really i see this is very much a
balance between that and the harm to the
countryside issue
just in terms of some detail
regarding screening i know that we've
heard that there's going to be quite a
lot of screening
is that something perhaps officers could
comment on regarding whether a condition
could be
added in terms of boundary screening i'm
thinking in particular and there is a
particular area where i think some
additional screening or a wall or fence
adjacent to hill place
would uh give more privacy to that
property and i think that's something
i'd like officers to comment on we've
touched on drainage uh already
i think the concerns expressed regarding
foul and surface water drainage i do
understand that that's normally looked
at
later and you've already confirmed
officers have confirmed that there won't
be any development unless those points
are properly
answered i mean i don't think there is
maine's uh connection to um sewage for
example i think it's obsessed
arrangement and i think as far as
surface water is concerned i think i
think if the landscaping can
take care of you've mentioned the park
car park area you know clearly there is
quite a lot of concern from the
neighbouring property hill place which
is some sort of 15 foot below where
these stables are so it's a reasonable
concern on gro on clay soil i think if
again if the conditionings can be
appropriate to ensure that
there is proper drainage
to take care of
any additional water or foul water
you mentioned condition 5 refers to the
class eg1
employment i think i would like officers
just to confirm categorically that there
is no that that would also cover sort of
auxiliary use
and that's something i'd like officers
to come back on
and final two points if i may chairman
we've touched on lighting i think we've
got to be quite specific here there is a
condition on lighting condition 16 which
refers to lighting mainly in respect of
it appears at first glance in respect of
looking after the bats
but i think if if officers could just
confirm that that lighting condition
also covers um the um
uh
the residents nearby
and that for example lighting
wouldn't necessarily be on the entrance
road where of course that would cause
most disruption to the nearby neighbours
in particular hill place
and then finally you've touched on signs
i mean my understanding
on signs advertisement signs is that
what we could expect here is a very
small discrete plaque advising where uh
where the where this business is there
would be no
this isn't other condition because it's
covered by rules and therefore we can't
we can perhaps give some comfort um to
mr goff that there won't be large
advertisements advertising uh the
accountancy or other business i think
those are the areas main areas of
questioning i have one other point uh
chairman which i may come to later just
regarding roofing but those are my main
questions which i'd just like to put to
through you to to officers uh perhaps
hannah in particular
sorry could you turn your microphone
please
yeah in respect to boundary treatments
um
we could add a condition so
um
so details can be approved prior to the
development if there's some additional
boundary treatments that we're looking
to secure that's not a problem
um in regards to the drainage any
any hard standing we do look for that to
be permeable
um
we can add an informative on just to say
we would like it to be permeable and
grass creep preferably
and that's not a problem either
in respect to the use as eg one
i would not consider it necessary to
make that any more robust i don't
i can't see any ancillary uses to an
office that would disturb neighbours and
if there was i would think that would be
outside of the used class and we'd be
looking to take enforcement action
so i think that condition is robust
enough
the lighting it does pertain to the bats
um
we'd also look we we can also consult
environmental health when that
lighting scheme comes in just to make
sure that it's not going to be too
bright and there's no adverse impact on
the neighbours in that respect they can
look at the wattage so they can be
consulted on the scheme also
and as you said with adverts with the
area of special control which which is
even more restrictive than deemed
consent for adverts they would only be
able to put up a small plaque
in the ground and that is all so i
wouldn't consider a condition necessary
for adverts
thank you thank you chairman on one
supplementary point of view just mention
it the roofing material at the moment is
um and i understand this uh they've gone
for
minimum change you know and uh uh so
that it does have least impact on the
countryside but the roofing at the
moment is originally red corrugated tin
which has gone black which looks awful
and uh i just wondered i noted i think
somewhere that the one of the conditions
is to replace like with like
my own personal view is that that might
be an unnecessarily restrictive
condition because certainly i think it
would uh look much much better if it was
if there was an element of choice uh
whether one could add it was a welsh
slate or tiles i think it wouldn't have
a further impact on the countryside but
it would look a lot better and i think
the condition is a bit tight at the
moment and that might be considered by
members thank you chairman
that would be submissive
consideration
through uk yeah the wording of the
condition would have to be altered just
to say details to be submitted prior to
their installation but yet that could be
done thank you
i've been very patient counselor darren
you're next thank you well that's the
co-word member thank you chairman
chairman um
we've heard that this is um policy uh
compliant now
the objector has expressed some
legitimate concerns um
which to mine
it certainly appears that each of those
have been uh addressed um clearly
the the pre-commencement conditions of
as we've now just discussed
building material samples to be
to be provided etc
external lighting scheme um
and the uh
surface water drainage um and and given
those
uh factors and the protections that
we've already discussed um i i'm i
certainly don't
feel that there's a major issue with
this anymore um and of course it is
purely non-residential and and of course
should that change anytime in the future
that would be the subject of the further
planning application which would be
discussed at that time
but uh on on that basis and i think the
conditions um very helpfully suggested
by uh mr golf um i i don't have a
problem with any of those um if members
share my view i'd be very happy to
um to propose that we agree the
officer's recommendations thank you i've
got council fleming and council white
i'm not quite sure who was first but
can i go for council funny
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
mr johnson or hannah um
mr goff referenced a used class m.a in
permitted development
just wondered whether you wanted to
expand further on that or provide
additional comment
and then also i note that um
there was no condition about ev charging
points at the offices i wondered whether
that was something that could be
included thank you
yeah through youtube um we can add the
charging point condition
we do for residential so it makes yeah
lot of senses
and in relation i think m b is now class
q
um we can't
correct me if i'm wrong michael but we
can't condition
it to not
um
to restrict that permitted development
right can we we that's not something we
can condition
you can't remove that anymore
limited
rights can't remove that anymore
not not for class q we can we can for
other elements of permitted development
but you can't restrict the class queue
okay thank you thank you councillor
might they council students please uh
thank you madam chairman i just say um i
you know of all the businesses it could
be it's uh effectively an owner-run
business it's an office it's the least
defensive business you could have and
you know what we need jobs uh children
going forwards need jobs and these barns
yeah they look okay but they're all
falling down and unless people use them
for businesses or residential they won't
be there in 10 years time so i actually
you know applaud the applicant they've
done um what the application was turned
down for before they've removed some of
the windows they've changed it they're
not altering it at all so um i'd i'd
like to propose that we approve the
application in line with office
recommendations and the suggested
conditions
i think i've got that from councillor
durham so if you'd secondly
right thank you well um
councillor stevens before we go any
further
in case there's any debate on that
proposal thank you chair
i do agree with what counselor white
well
what everybody has said really but um on
the subject of electric charging points
for cars and and things related that was
one of my thoughts as well but also
we're talking about the roof but i'm not
seeing anything about photovoltaic
tiles in the roof
and an office is going to be quite power
hungry i would assume there will be
computers people working after dark
people want to be heated
i don't know much about plumbing but
maybe that involves some electrics as
well i don't know i just feel as soon as
i see a roof i see an opportunity really
and i don't see anything about an air
source heat pump or similar um i don't
know if conditions can be added for
those sorts of things but
i'm disappointed really to see
applications coming in with no mention
of this stuff and i don't think this
does mention those things
thank you okay yes um
this wouldn't be the scale of
development for which we could impose
such a condition such that if the
condition couldn't be complied with
refuse to scream
thank you chad i just wanted to go back
to what hannah was talking about earlier
about condition b and q
so hannah just to clarify are you saying
that
you can't restrict if this
is passed you can't restrict permitted
development rights after
one once it's been converted to offices
through uk you can't restrict the class
queue where it's the change of use but
it does have to meet the criteria and i
don't remember off the top of my head
but i believe it has to be
out of use for so long which is why
i don't think you can you can't put a
condition on to say
to remove that permitted development
right specifically
but it does have to meet other criteria
which obviously there would be a lap
some time before it would
i hope that makes sense thank you chair
yeah thank you chairman uh having asked
the questions earlier just in terms of
sort of debate um the larger issues i i
think as i kicked off with i think the
employment case is well made well
researched and it is a family business
as councils have pointed out um who
clearly would like to operate uh an
accountancy business or similar uh in in
in the countryside and they've obviously
paid a lot of attention to trying to
minimize the impact on the countryside
and uh they've obviously tried you know
done their homework we
if it is approved i think we've gone
through those conditions which hopefully
would go some way towards or satisfying
near neighbours that this will be uh as
least intrusive as possible um and uh i
think uh uh you know if we can pay
attention to all of those points i think
i think
on balance we should you know support an
employment opportunity
thank you
um we have a proposal on the table duly
seconded
no one else wishes to
wishes to speak let's take a vote so
those in favor of the proposal to
approve
right that's everyone thank you
none against no abstentions
so thank you that
that
application is approved in line not only
with the officers recommendations but
also with all the
extra conditions we've noted so thank
you very much
okay the next one is
number 38 woodruff road toll spring
um so can we have some
presentation please
thank you chair
uh the application is for a one and a
half story side extension with the
dormer windows to the front and rear to
match the existing dwelling
multiple
uh this is the application site
that's still working
the proposed block plan
no it's just what was just me
that's the usual reason it's a message
i'm go too far away sorry ladies it's
only bluetooth
uh here is the existing elevations
the proposed elevations showing the
dormer to the front
and the door to the rear and the side
extensions
the existing floor plans
the proposed floor plan
photos from the rear
and showing each side of the neighbors
from the room
and then photos from the front
and that's it thank you chad
oh it's up for refusal sorry
thank you right well we don't have any
public speakers on
this one so um
and this is here because it's a member
of staff ordinarily be a delegated
decision
so who forgot that's the case
um
well we only have the one local
development plan so it's basically
whoever gets the hand up first but
obviously obviously i will come to
council stevens in due course
uh yes please do council students
thank you chair thank you [ __ ]
councillor
um
yes i'm the award member for tollsbury
um
the building works proposed in itself
probably would be fine but it is the the
house next door i agree with everything
that the officers report states about
the height of it the proximity to the
house next door blocking the light from
the next door bedroom window which you
can see quite clearly in the top right
picture there which window is already
restricted from the carport there it's
got a slightly see-through roof but the
lights already dimmed must be
um it's a very overbearing
look to it because the house on the
right that's to be extended is quite a
long way up hill from the other the hill
is fairly steep there
i think it would just be grossly unfair
on the neighbours next door and it
wouldn't look good
thank you
um i think council reviews was next then
could i go to the site plan place where
i got the the road plan because i was
just looking at the one next door i
thought this was very tight to the
boundary but the one next door's
right up against it
there we go number 36
that's bang on the bloody boundary so
38.
[Music]
are they sort of attached through the
beds
um
so there's already a carport there
so i just want to come out the same
go up and come to the there's a fence as
to the fence line as i get as well
i mean cover the area of the car
probably and higher
yes yes i think they exist in the ridge
towing off the existing room
and there's just one window the other
side of that building isn't there which
you can't see nothing there because
there's a fence there surely
serves
the next picture in place
where that window is that i say is
obscured
it's gonna be dull if there's a fence
there anyway isn't it was that what was
in the report yeah
the light of that existing window is
already restricted yeah
um it's not completely restricted um
you know the carpet is fairly open it's
got a
translucent roof
uh however the
the first law extension would extend
over the whole area of that carport
at the full height of the roof so you're
looking at something which is completely
overbearing and completely block out the
light
would be
any level of
aspect that they have
the ground always open because that's
where the front doors to the property
and it also serves a car
i think also as the report steps out
it's the juxtaposition given the slope
of the land given the height of the
building you know the the low line level
of the bundle
in design terms as well they would look
in congress as a street scene
where on the road from there's clearly a
change
in design pattern as you come down
that
the platform changes into a much more
open
aspect
so this is what the report's drawing out
but particularly anna's raised in the
objection through the neighbors between
the impact on the release
i think you have to bear in mind i mean
i have no idea who lives there now or
their circumstances but i think you have
to bear in mind there might end up
someone in that bedroom who spends a
good deal of time in there
for various reasons um that's an
important point because in in playing
law it's not just about
decisions we made for an individual
once that decision is being built in the
exactly um would you like to continue to
project councils impossible to move
where that says teams north so i can see
that house on the right hand side
oh well done okay
no it's not about it so
to the flank of the of the
number
36
so there is no impact in terms of their
immunity the garden area is far shallow
at the back the predominant garden
is to the south of number third to the
guardians of that has an open aspect so
that's a completely different
relationship but that's a relationship
between this
uh and there are no rules i think
so it's just clear that we made that
decision
i think even if something something else
nearby isn't perfect that isn't any
reason to allow oh he's socializing
you're trying to keep a big consistency
okay well i
the council's students should come back
just to come back on that if i may chair
um the house that you can see at the so
the bottom right hand picture the house
that you can see at the top right hand
side of that i think is considerably
older than the semis that you see to the
left and that exists that
juxtaposition must have been in place
now for about
50 years or something so i don't think
decisions we made then
really have a lot to do with what's
happening now thank you everything else
is what it is it's a case of where we go
from here now um counselor durham you
were
no thank you
the only thing
anything that springs to my mind is why
on earth do they build a bedroom window
so close to their garden fence that just
seems of it
when it was originally done that didn't
seem like they had an awful lot of
forethought on it
with how close it was because that's
dark anyways it's really really dark
that seems like a very strange place to
put a bedroom window you know right on
the boundary fence because that looks
like it's only a couple of feet away
and and presumably the people who are
there they could cover that roof in
black tin if they wanted to of the
carport i don't imagine there's a
condition saying it's got to be
translucent
um i don't know what to do with this one
actually i'm sort of sitting on it i
don't normally refuse them extensions
but i really don't know what to do it's
just like ooh
maybe the fence wasn't certainly clever
who knows
cancer morning
the house for the bedroom
who who built what when and when anybody
moved in
council jones yeah thank you chairman i
think um i think that was going to be my
point really we don't really know uh why
they put a window there i mean um
obviously we don't know this internal
sort of internal rooms within the house
they've got to have a bedroom somewhere
most rooms that you would want a window
and probably when that window was put in
you know it had some light
so we don't really know the background
to it
i don't think you know if they'd have
had options i'm sure they'd put the room
the bedroom somewhere else but they
perhaps they didn't have options but i
think we have to judge it based on
what's there at the moment
as to whether it would uh
whether it is unreasonable to to for a
new extension um to to sort of cut out
the light completely and that's really
what i think the subject of discussion
that we have to determine this evening
thank
you propose that we
um move the officer's recommendation to
approve
refuse sorry yeah
sorry can we try again are you proposing
the officers i propose that we move the
officer's recommendation
oh we've got two of those but cancer
jobs first
okay any further debate on that
you know your questions answered members
um if so i'll put that to the vote so
those in favor of the office's
recommendation which is to
refuse
one two three four okay and
those against
one two three
council of the dharam
thinking or abstaining
fair enough
okay so the um that item is in fact
refused in line with the officer's
recommendation
i think i'd just like to say that um
you know i i the reason i i went against
the officer's recommendation was because
i think the next door neighbors can put
up a six foot fence and they can make
the roof black and and it won't be any
worse
if it's a as a story and a half so
that's that's why
i i actually went against the officer's
recommendation
okay right hold on
we have item seven any other items of
business the chairman of the committee
sides are urgent and you'll be grateful
to oh council stevens
sorry
sorry i was just going to ask on the
tail end of this last item something
which i think would really help in
future decisions and would have helped
with this one is having the google
street view because i'm looking at it
here and now that we've finished
debating anyone's welcome to come and
have a look at this on my screen and i
think they'll see where i'm coming from
applicants always only show what they're
applying for and not the whole thing in
context and i think it would be really
really helpful if the planning officers
are able to get some pictures of the
street scene because you can get much
more from that sometimes thank you
please
there are no other roads and the third
urgent items of pinterest
thank you very much
yeah i think that councillor stevens is
right i actually pulled it up on um
street view while we were in very well
we were discussing and actually it was
much clearer yeah thank you
okay um well thank you members thank you
to members of the public out there um
and i close the meeting at 20 23. thank
you
you